stop making fun of me oh my god billy
eilish wants you to stop
talking about her hair i have a fun
story to tell you but first
[ __ ] you guys stop making fun of me oh
my god i'm
making you an album i will not put it
out if you keep making fun of my hair
shut up on monday the 19 year old singer
hit up her insta story to clap back at
fans who had been knocking her for
rocking those iconic green roots
for what they think is just a little too
long
dude here's the thing bro billy first
debuted the look on instagram in july
2019
after previously sporting blue then
black locks
really really cool and basically it's
been her signature look
ever since the things that people sort
of know me for are all the things i want
to be known for
well fans have been teasing the grammy
winner for a while now pointing out that
it's the longest she's
ever committed to one style one user
even not so nicely called her
grasshead writing that she needs a new
color
not only did billy respond on her insta
story
she also snapped back in the comments
writing it's called
not being depressed anymore please just
be happy for me
yeah and she didn't stop there the ocean
eyes singer added quote
this is the longest i've had the same
hair color since i was 13.
and that's on mental stability and
growth leave me alone
and back on her insta story she revealed
that she will be changing her hair
after the release of her apple tv
documentary the worlds a little blurry
which is scheduled to drop in february
i'm changing it after the dock comes out
it'll be the end of an
era i'm gonna give you a new era
[Music]
i have announcements to make i got
something to put out
anyway doesn't matter leave me alone let
me live with my [ __ ]
hair that i've had for way too long okay
billy went on to like a whole slew of
posts about her hair
including this one that said fans would
be begging for the green to come back
before long i'm not bored of it at all i
love it
anyway after billy told fans to cool it
she shared a wild story about her
beloved pitbull
shark who was throwing up all over her
house
we're like what the [ __ ] did this dude
eat because he eats crazy
anything on the ground he'll just eat it
doesn't matter what it is he's a [ __ ]
dog that's what they do
but usually what happens is he'll eat
something weird and he'll throw it right
up and i'll be totally fine and move on
with his day
he's done this before so and we've taken
him to the vet before and they're like
usually like oh you'll be fine i'll pass
it
well not this time billy said they took
shark to the vet
where they did an x-ray and spotted
something that was stuck in his
intestines
so they did surgery to remove it and
billy revealed the shocking mystery item
you're ready for this this is what they
pulled out of his
they cut open his intestine and pulled
this out okay he swallowed it
you know the weirdest part about this
i've never
seen that toy in my life thankfully
shark is now recovering and
so is billy after having quite the
milestone year
which included performances at the
oscars the democratic national
convention
and the grammys where she collected five
trophies including the top four awards
of the night
this is like a dream a dream right it's
a dream